foreign
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
Rangers keep it in
50 seconds remaining in the power
play the stuff shot Opportunity
by Cooley is stop and the Bruins clear
broken up before it could reach heatel
Jones walks the line for in the air from the
wall slides it down low a chance stop by Bussey
that's a good stop right there good
Movement by the Rangers Power Play
I don't know about threatened but uh I'm certainly
there's some players in the lineup tonight for
the Boston Bruins it could probably give you
a little bit more in terms of noticeability
here the deeper we get into this hockey game
that is our expectations but you know it's
always good to hear the team president talk about
opportunity I mean it's coming right from the top
and if you deserve to be in the Bruins
uniform and playing on a regular basis
you will be a gift this one all the
way down ice Jonathan Quick goes to
play and has a little trouble with it
but Brayden Schneider there to clean up
now Anton bleed looks to work left side to the net
stop the rebound poked at it as well and somehow
Bussey is able to cover it up wasn't sure where it
was good strong move there by Anton bleed [Music]
I sell is kind of cherry picking negating
the icy backhand chance rebound from Bussey
is Frozen for a whistle loses that one now
as a ball has his pocket pick by needle good
check there by Laughlin here but the Bruins take
the puck and lift it high into the neutral zone
oh there's a giveaway by Steiner and
quick is there to bail him out with a stop
[Music]
that puck out a turnover and
a chance in tight on quick
Richard lingering there and the puck came right
to him Andrew's now out shooting the Bruins 12-9
other turnover and another
opportunity they score it is Deborah
this line accounts for both goals for the Brewers
two nothing this is an even straight goal and it's
a beauty nice bat out of mid air right there to
keep the play alive that's the brush nice little
look there on the back going by then this is an
even strength goal and it's a beauty nice bat
out of mid air right there to keep the player
alive that's the brush nice little look there
on the back door by Van Reems Dyke and there's
that kid again Patois with a nice little feed
even though he's in the middle of the ice
you would think shot shot but he probably
says I'm too far out I don't have the
NHL staying with it and finding a way to
finally make it up to the big leagues here's
an opportunity for Jimmy veezy cuts to the net
and it's stopped terrific save by Bussey
on a nice move by veezy taking it to the
net down the right side that really was a
great move and it was just a better save
by Emerson applying the body here's an outlet for
VC darting to the net save Bussey and
he closes his pads to cover the puck
certainly under a lot more pressure in this
period busting through shot score John Beecher
[Music] well he's one of those guys battling
for a forward spot and he puts the Bruins third
goal tonight especially for big man and
again it's tomorrow love this kid's hands
he's able to make a play through Center rice
no one's catching feature at that point they
don't pick him up in the neutral zone you're
just going to see 19 as you're chasing on the
back Jack that's a pretty nice little release
five hole before quick get down the stick not
in position former 30th overall selection from the
Bruins and his second professional season turnover
to La froniere Club saved by Bussey flashing
the leather on the former first overall pick
he allowed that goal against Chris
Kreider with a minute 28 remaining
in game six of the first round
playoffs two post seasons ago that
pushed the Rangers to a game six win which set up
the artemi Panera in overtime win in game seven
which he did not play this opportunity in front
what a stop what a stop by Bussey against belzyl
Louis de Ming inspected in the
next lead three nothing Schneider
sneaking a shot high and wide isn't it
easy tight turn walks to the front loose
Puck fussy kept it out stacking the pass
and now Frederick able to clear it out as
Mitchell hops out of the Penalty Box Rangers
0 for three with the man advantage four and
a half minutes remaining in the second period
nice pass there that rear shot off the crossbar
something you don't see every day [Applause]
in front lead was wide open but
it slid off his stick Rangers
got the Bruins and a change and
that's what led to that chance
bounced away from Anton's lead
don't see him on the bench though and he left
about four minutes into the second period remember
blocked a shot earlier in the game and did not
take a shift after about the four minute Mark
of the second period not on the bench to begin
was blocked out by the lines but on
that attempt to pass he goes after it
again gets the puck back takes it to
the middle down low it goes and that
shot stop while Bernier was stopped and
heedle was stimied on the rebound finally
bossy again comes up big twice with a save heedle
with the second bid and the left
pad got to it elzil Nash veezy
who comes to the top of the crease and again
holds on a beautiful passing Again by the Rangers
no rebound Adam edstrom for the
mid slot but Bussey read it the
whole way rotates to Jones touch pass La
brunier nicely done across it goes [Music]
are you kidding me Brandon Bussey for
game one of the exhibition schedule
good attendance here tonight they're being
treated for some pretty impressive bolt on it
he'd get deep and he's got to keep that glove out
in front of the goal line and somehow catch it I
mean that's a one-timer on a well-executed play
by the Rangers for the Bruins five seconds away
from being complete one last chance and it stays
out on the outside of the goal and that doesn't
on 29 save shutout for Brandon Bussey
and the Bruins win it three nothing